action will always be any kind of
intention when things get tough
especially in Ultra or in life in
general I'll think in my head like can I
take another step and you absolutely
basically always can there's very few
moments in life where physically you
can't take another step so if I can I
will if you think about that really
deeply you
can when you think of an ultr Runner
what usually comes to mind is is a
certain look a certain lifestyle you
know the guy who lives in a van down by
the river with the Epic beard or the
Glorious mustache well suffice it to say
that William gu stands quite opposite
this archetype he's clean shaven and
always perfectly groomed he's a former
model who Sports a uniquely muscled
physique which is rather uncommon among
endurance athletes and he's a guy who
simply isn't isn't afraid to rock a
Prada manur and you know what will gu is
100% Unapologetic about any of it he is
always authentically himself and I got
to tell you I just love that about him
his resume speaks for itself recently
will ran across the entire United States
quite Fleet footed covering the distance
in a blazing 55 plus days which is a
feat that very few can best and along
the way
somehow made it look fun he's also
completed 50 marathons in 50 days he
circumnavigated Lake Cuomo and he's run
from lanen to Jon o' groz every effort
in honor of his mother who passed away
too soon from cancer and every event a
campaign to raise funds for cancer
research so today we get into it we dive
into his story we talk about his Unique
Style his motivations his big
achievements and the lessons learn
learned along the way including the ins
and outs of the controversy that swirled
around his transcon run blw here from
England to debunk that we're doing
you're somehow not running it publicly
will has become a good friend he's
definitely a fun hang and uh I think
you're going to relish his unique lens
on Sport and
[Music]
life good to see you man thank good to
see man I'm uh I'm excited to talk to
you about this it's been really fun
getting to know you over the past couple
years mostly at a distance um but we had
a couple moments in London I just knew
uh you know the minute that you were
going to do this transcon thing that
when it was all wrapped up that you had
to come in and share some stories from
the front lines and there's a lot to
share about this experience there's a
few stories along the way first of all
how are you feeling recovering I mean
that was in the spring so you're how
many weeks out from completing it uh it
was five almost 5 weeks ago I finished
mhm so not that long a time but the that
5 weeks has gone incredibly quickly it's
been a bit of a blur yeah having a good
time yeah maybe not the best recovery
techniques but mentally though maybe
optimal yeah right I allowed myself
space after such like a a big effort I
was very conscious along the way that
afterwards I was going to allow myself
some freedoms to enjoy things afterwards
so there's been no moments of like oh no
like should I have done that I not done
that I've just been given myself
ultimate space and I feel very free and
fortunate to be in that head space yeah
well you're not one to shy away from a
good
time right which speaks to a larger very
interesting um conversation around you
as this very unique manifestation of an
ultr Runner like you you are one of the
things I love about you is you're just
100% unapologetically you and and I
think whereas most ultr Runners adhere
to a certain let's call it archetype
personality or identity like a sort of
dirt bag Lifestyle the beard the
mustache the you know living in the
mountains or you know in a van down by
the river you describ R I know we are
yes I'm speaking to you directly Robbie
um and he's like your best friend we're
going to get into that it's a very
interesting friendship but you uh
William are a very different sort of lad
mate um a guy who who you know I guess
and correct me if you think this is
unfair you live a bit of uh Beyond The
Velvet Rope type of Lifestyle um you
fancy a posh hotel suite and a nice
breakfast and the Michelin star
restaurants and a good party and front
row seats at Paris fashion week which is
where where you were last week right
like you know you're not the normal ultr
Runner guy which probably Ruffles a few
feathers which we can get into um people
who maybe have a hard time understanding
why you want to share your skincare
routine Etc but I love you for that and
I think there's a freshness in your
approach uh that brings that breathes a
little bit of fresh air into a rather
cloyed kind of subculture so how do you
think about yourself in the context of
that broader kind of Eco system or do
you not think about that at all and
you're just you um I I can consider it
but like you said I am just doing kind
of what I want to do and Ultra came to
me well it was like five and a half
years ago so it's relatively new in
terms of my sort of adult life and what
I've been doing so I've just continued
doing what I was doing before but added
ultra running into it and I've kind of
been shaped from uh a big loss in my
family and I'm very conscious of the
fact that tomorrow is not promised so I
very much live that way in every day of
my life and that can be it can be good
and it can be bad but I'm trying to
squeeze as much out of life through
experience
travel eating nice food seeing
interesting things as I can and it might
not as you say adhere to the the typical
ultr
running space or I'm I'm not running 100
mile weeks normally but like my biggest
asset I would say is my mental space and
when when [__] gets tough like that's
when I'm really ready to go so all those
side things that I do become irrelevant
at the time when when they need to be
but where does that come from speak a
little bit about you know how you define
that for yourself that that mental
Advantage uh well seeing my mom battle
cancer three times only knew twice but
she passed away it was five sorry four
and a half years ago she passed away um
seeing her fight cancer for me imprinted
something in my brain where when things
get tough especially in Ultra in life in
general the way I think about things is
if someone's fighting for their life
they haven't chosen to be in that
position they are quite literally
fighting for your life if you're outside
running doing a 100 mile race I'll I'll
think in my head when when it's getting
hard like can I take another step and I
and you absolutely basically always can
there's very few moments in life where
physically you can't take another step
and I'm relatively healthy I'm young and
everything I do is in her memory and in
her name so out of respect of her and
trying to make her death mean something
more than just a sad story I will always
always persevere and take that extra
step what was it about your mom and the
way that you she raised you and your
relationship with her that has made her
such an
indelible um presence in your life even
after her
passing she was the best version of
everything you can imagine she was the
sweetest kindest person person to
everyone in life but when it came to
family she'd be very protective as well
she'd always put herself second or third
or fourth whoever whoever else is around
she'd always put them in front she was
happiest making other people happy um
and for me she was the first person I'd
talk to if I got the best news in the
world and she'd be the first person I'd
talk to if I got the worst news in the
world
so losing losing her would if if I had
to choose the number one person not to
lose it would have been it would have
been my mom most definitely so when she
passed like I was 23 bad time to W bad
time to lose a parent anytime at 23 I
was sort of mature enough to have my own
life and be able to make my own choices
but not very mature in terms of like
what I'd been through so there was these
contrasting things it was like I kind of
want to forget about what's going on
here and people said at the beginning I
dealt with it too well um it was
obviously a mask but I could have gone
one way of trying to numb it out with
drugs alcohol parting that kind of thing
but there was just like a there was a
very poignant thing in the back of my
head and out of respect for her that I
had to I couldn't I couldn't waste it
away even if it was for a year or two I
had to had to persevere straight away
and I didn't know what the [__] I was
going to do by the way running just kind
of came to me and we can get into that
but yeah I think should be other than
being concerned when I do the biggest
stuff she'd definitely be proud of what
I've made of it my sense is that the
early phases of your running career
which hasn't been that long of a career
what like three years or so since you
started when you first laced up right um
that experience was born out of
confusion and grief and trying to make
sense of of this loss um perhaps a
little bit of anger as an outlet um a
healthier Outlet than drugs and alcohol
and partying and the like um but the
fuel source being those challenging
emotions as opposed to the more
sustainable fuel of of Joy or pursuing a
goal or unlocking potential like those
are things that came later yeah I was
definitely very angry at the start um I
lived a very fortunate
upbringing we were middle class family
in the UK in a small country town there
was always food on the table we went on
a family holiday every year
parents were were still together never
really argued like if I had to choose a
childhood for eventually when I have
children I'd want it to be like that
like it was absolutely perfect no no
like luxuries or Thrills but I couldn't
have been happier growing up do you have
siblings one older brother yeah mhm yeah
so what does he make of all this what
does he do what's his story he's um he's
in construction he was in he was in
farming and agriculture before so we we
went on different tangents like can I
remember growing up we both played rugby
but when rugby ended for him he went
more Agricultural and like shooting and
things like that and I went more like to
the S Urban I went more urban way I
started doing modeling and things like
that so that took me on a different path
but we get on very well we're we're
we're different but similar at the same
time um and it's it's been interesting
for him and my dad as well of me of them
being within the story as well because
obviously them seeing their son or
brother do some of the things I've done
like it's sometimes confusing for them
but it's I I think it's helped them deal
with the process as well yeah it was fun
to see your dad in the audacious report
videos that Reese made um sort of
baffled you know but like amused by the
whole thing and and and you know present
but also not sure what he was supposed
to do while he was on the road with you
guys like absolute Legend and and like a
character yeah he get him and Robbie get
on real well cuz they're just always
looking for the next Pub and ironically
he came in the Navajo Nation where it's
yeah not a lot ofs a dry state so yeah
but um yeah for him it's I can't imagine
what it's been like for him with the
pressure of having two sons as well um
and I remember when I did Jon o great
Salan end he came up at really that
ruined me entirely that was like my
rebirth I think um but he came up at a
bad time where I was I'd been taking
coding a bit too much I was a I was a
moving zombie um and yeah he's he's had
difficulty understanding why I do it but
he's grown in confidence as I continue
to do it the first time he thought I was
on a self-destruction path which I kind
of was um but I guess with the success
is it he still doesn't quite understand
why the hell I do it but he's more at
peace with it now it feels like you have
a healthier relationship with you're
running now though yeah for sure it's
more of like a celebration and in some
ways when I started I didn't I didn't
know well I didn't have a plan I still
don't really have like a a plan of where
this is going to go but I've started
achieving things that have given me
confidence to maybe push on and and try
and do other things or be more
competitive in in the races I do enter
or do so around the time that your mom
uh was diagnosed with cancer you're
living in London and pursuing modeling
were you playing rugby at that time or
you had just been a former rugby player
yeah I was playing rugby at the time and
I was spending a lot of time here in La
as well cuz my ex-girlfriend was here so
yeah I was splitting time a lot when I
could I'd finish a game and might fly
here for a few days and during summer
and the like the winter break I'd be
here as well so yeah and then she she
gets
ill um how long was her battle well she
F she first had it she had had it for
about a year before she went into
remission and this is probably the
origin story of why I got into running
and why I do it if I had to pinpoint the
happiest moment of my life it's very
clear in my head it was when I came here
nine nine months before she actually
passed away I was in Santa Monica and at
the time by the way I hated running
running was a punishment I I was playing
rugby the contact sport like you're
going to score a try you're going to
tackle someone really hard your
teammate's going to go do something good
it's like camaraderie running for me was
a punishment it's like if you [__] up
in training or was late go and do some
laps so the thought of going for a run
for me was I didn't understand why
anyone would do it but upon this time
coming back to LA it was to meet who my
ex my who was going to become my
girlfriend for the first time so I was
excited about that uh woke up at like
4:00 in the morning I like [__] what am
I going to do just wait for this chick
to wake up the jet lag I was like if
there's ever a time where I might enjoy
run might it's probably now I'm in a
really good mood I'm right by the beach
I'll probably I'll run up to Malibu I'll
run along the beach wait for the sun to
rise and then I'll go back so I did do
that left my shoes at reception which
was an interesting choice I don't know
why I did that and then I ran ran Santa
Monica went down onto the boardwalk it
was the wooden one at the time and I ran
all the way to the end where you
couldn't go any further I think it's a
Pacific Highway and sure becomes
mountainous then the only way to get
back was to turn around and run back
when I got back I had like blood
blisters all over my feet why did you
choose to do that Barefoot cuz I assumed
like I might run on the sand I didn't um
she was quite beused but I got back and
that was the first long run I've ever
done so I think I checked like N9 months
later it was maybe 8 Miles definitely
way further than i' I'd ever ran when I
got back into the room I was just in
like this buoyant mood I was like what's
going on maybe it's cuz I'm seeing this
girl for the first time whatever
whatever and then my mom actually called
and she had been to see a doctor and she
she was in remission so that that moment
there day was just a encapsulation of so
many good things happening at once and
yeah the cancer came back what probably
two or three months later and then she
ended up passing away in the January
January 15th
2018 um and yeah I at the time I'd had
to take six weeks off from rugby because
I kept I kept getting knocked out I kept
failing the return to play protocol had
head scans I was okay but not well
enough to go back and she was always
like my champion at rugby she's always
on the sideline she' travel away gam
should' be everywhere and when I tried
to go back to that I was having a real
hard time and like my the team
understood and like management and said
just take as much time as you want um
and in that time I just found myself
running I didn't actually know why might
be 3:00 in the morning I'd be really
[__] pissed off or I'd be or I'd be
crying uncontrollably and I'd find
myself just getting my shoes and I'd do
the the same route I was in the family
home at the time small town in Bedford
sh I'd run and do this 5K Loop over and
over again um and upon self-reflection
and obviously figuring it out along the
way and doing things I've done I
realized I've been trying to get back to
that moment at the end of that run and
here in La yeah that's that's an
interesting
self-awareness that experience lodged in
your brain like a sliver in your brain
mhm like the first time you do heroin
and then it's just about like trying to
recapture that first experience I'll let
you know how it goes yeah how's it
playing out you're chasing the dragon
pretty hard my friend and then on top of
that some brain injury it's all it all
makes sense now like I'm now I'm getting
a clear picture of the whole thing um
yeah but clearly running steps in almost
on an unconscious level as a as a coping
mechanism as a defense mechanism for
dealing with challenging emotions and
that you didn't know how to process in
any other way yeah it's very true and
yeah I was I was searching for something
and I didn't know what it was but at the
time all all I knew
was whatever when I went for a run and
came back I'd feel a little bit better
than I did before and I might start
sprinting when I'm out there and crying
down the road whatever but when I got
back I
was less of an in a destru Ive that's an
experience I think a lot of people can
probably relate to I'm sure it's not
that uncommon but what isn't uncommon is
you at some point making a decision to
you know tackle some pretty large
challenges like that's a leap so where
does that come into play like at what
point do you decide this is not enough
now I need to go do something super hard
and why it was after my first marathon
so she passed away in January and the
following December Christmas time
Christmas was I was not looking forward
to it you know how when you when you
lose someone very close to you every
very special occasion suddenly becomes
one you want to avoid or not so special
or something's missing so I was actively
trying to get out of Christmas any way I
could but do it under the cloak of it
being accepted rather than just like
hiding away or whatever I had been
running a bit so I thought well what
better opportunity to do my first
marathon than Christmas day I'll avoid
most of Christmas and then afterwards
I'll be too tired to be involved in it
so so yeah I decided to raise money for
McMillan cancer support as well they're
charity in the UK they offer support to
cancer sufferers family friends whatever
like if you can't afford to get to your
doctor's appointment they'll book you a
taxi they've got a 24-hour care service
so if you got any questions you can call
them up they have nurses so the McMillan
nurses personally cared for my mom when
she was at Bedford Hospital so I wanted
to do something for them cuz they' had
been so brilliant us and the family um
the route was from my family home to
Bedford Hospital where she actually
worked as a nurse as well and had a load
of her treatment around like her family
homes she grew up as and then back to
ampor around all our family homes or the
ones we lived in that in that town
raised like £20,000 M and all of a
sudden I had this very positive feedback
from something I was using negatively
and that really solidified as soon as I
did that like I was broken my first
marathon was really hard like it is for
everyone yeah um but as soon as I did
that I just I had the seed was planted
in my head I wanted to do something
bigger and better and the first thing I
could think of was running from the top
of the UK to the bottom not even what
everyone does Jon gr lend or lanen to
Jon o gr I literally drew a line from
the top of Scotland That's how little
you knew about that's how I knew legy of
these sorts of events yeah I didn't know
anyone that was doing it that's actually
that's actually how I ended up meeting
Robbie along this journey of starting to
run the length of the UK but yeah I had
no anchor no knowledge it was just I
knew I needed to do it and wanted to do
it and it kind of just got bigger and
bigger as I went right so talk a little
bit about that that Jon o' gr's
experience like you you kind of just
launched into it not really knowing
anything and just gung-ho hoed it right
like yeah and where does Robbie come in
it was concerning actually thinking
about it's concerning like I remember
like 10 days before I started one of my
like brother's closest friend who's like
a family friend anyway called me and
asked me all these questions like just a
list of have you done this I was like no
you done this no have you done this no
he was like okay I'm going to come help
you cuz he works in event marketing so
knew at least something he knew what he
kind of knew what to do but yeah that's
that's how I've lived my life I've got a
little bit better but not much better
but when I announced I was going to run
run the length of the UK I was coming
back and forth to La cuz I was still
with my girlfriend at the time I went to
this random cryotherapy place and the
guy in there said you should follow
Robbie Ballinger on Instagram he's
running across the US and I was like I
absolutely should follow that guy I
actually called him Robbie Banger at the
time and I I watched him from like day
seven to day 75 when he finished and I
was obsessed like I said a minute ago I
had no anchor I had no I had no
knowledge I didn't know who like Dean
kazis was I didn't know David goggin was
didn't know Kil and J had no names all
of a sudden had Robbie
banger and I yeah as I said I was
obsessed I sent a few messages along the
way like watching what he was doing and
then I waited till I think it was like
10 days after he finished cuz I knew
there might be loads of loads of [__]
going on I just sent a message saying
like what I think you've done is
incredible I gave a brief backstory of
myself and what I was about to do and
just asked I was like can I send you
some questions via email or can we jump
on a call and yeah he got back pretty
quickly and was just like yeah
absolutely free in the next few days
whatever so we get on a call I tell him
what I'm doing he's down to help and
yeah they say the rest is history but in
one of when I was training I went out to
Colorado with him he took me on a 10mile
trail run of Boulder as soon as I
arrived from the UK as well by the way
I'd flown to La slept for like 2 hours
flown to Denver he' picked me up and
we'd gone straight to Boulder altitude I
had no experience altitude and he takes
me on [__] mountain goat takes me a
10 mile trail run around Boulder which
was horrible that's a lightning bolt
moment though to go into a random cryo
place and just have some stranger tell
you you should look at this guy like had
you decided not to go to that like what
would your life look like like you have
no idea well you do now but how lucky
you were to have found this incredible
Angel this spirit that is Robbie the
most giving like open gracious um
service-minded person you know
imaginable like the perfect kind of
Sherpa for you yeah I don't actually
want to think about that not happening
it's in it's insane like everything he's
done for me he's been on every challenge
I've done yeah he's been there in a big
way he's like um I mean that guy shows
up he knows how to show up for the
people he cares about yeah I have a
different connection with him than
anyone else in the world like we
understand each other in a different way
whereas like even with my dad and my
brother they're still like what the [__]
are you doing which is interesting
because you are very different people
yeah we are but we get on yeah we get on
super well and I think we have the same
I think we have similar tendencies in
you know pushing pushing the boundaries
of stuff whether that be physical or
mental or both or yeah he's had an
interesting past and yeah for sure he
wasn't was he on site for the Jon o' grz
run yeah he came for he came for the
whole thing when we were in um when we
were in Colorado and saw him for the
first time he shows me this Excel
spreadsheet that had been done by is um
his father-in-law and mother-in-law of
like every single day detailed how many
miles he going to run What mileage the
shoe was in what food it was going to
eat how many calories it had for serving
and I was there going I don't have an I
don't have a spreadsheet yeah did you
realize maybe you were in over your head
yeah I had a route I had a rout from
what was her name I forget her name but
she had just got the record as the
fastest British the fastest woman to do
Jan's end I think it's since been taken
but I messaged her and she was like yeah
here's my route so that's literally all
I had right and that evening when we
were looking over things he just stopped
for a second paused and he was
like I think I'm going to come help you
and I was like what I had I have I had a
real hard job understanding why someone
would help me in kind of anything I did
I I liked helping other people but I
found it very difficult to accept help I
don't know what that comes from or just
trying to be like a man like I have to
do everything um but yeah he was like
I've just been away for a few months so
I need to check with my fiance at the
time Shelly now wife um he'd get back to
me so yeah he came for the whole thing
and what was that experience like like
what did you learn well I learned in
your first you know tackling your first
really big thing um I learned not to
take coding yeah that's not smart it was
this I'm basically saying how stupid I
used to be this is an insight into my
part of being an idiot but I was very
naive and to be fair actually to back
myself up a little bit the crew knew I
was doing it so let's give them some of
it but but the idea was like to numb out
like whatever pain you were feeling but
then you're like getting you know
mentally you're it was insane checking
out so in the buildup I'd done three
marathons one of them Christmas Day and
then two other madeup ones and I'd done
two Ultras and I'd never ran the day
after doing any of that stuff then all
so MDS you did MDS before that no after
the the first Ultra I did was London to
Brighton which is 100k or 62 Mi and then
I did one a few months later called the
war which is from car in the UK to
Newcastle that was 111 so about 67 miles
and then I said I was going to go and
run the length of the UK I think I said
14 days which is how many miles uh I
averaged 55 in the end but I think it
needed to be closer to 60 but that's my
naivity so that shows why the ironic
thing was the coding I took was Mom's
pain medicine I also had liquid oramorph
which is um what's it called whatever
it's like heroin oh wow liquid oramorph
is morphine it's liquid morphine sorry
so I I didn't actually take that but
every day I was taking for the first
nine days eight coding pills I read the
outside of the packet said may cause
drowsiness and in my head I'm like I'm
running 16 to 18 hours a day Onin this
thing I'm going to be tired anyway so a
little bit extra tiredness for the
painfree or at least a little bit
painfree might be a good idea obviously
it turned out not to be didn't Robbie
try to talk you out of that it was it
was funny
because my girlfriend at the time
messaged I think it was on day nine and
she was concerned cuz I hadn't been
responding like at all I was in total
zombie mode I wasn't sleeping at night I
was hallucinating most the day when I
got into bed at night there'd be one
position that hurt more than another but
I'd I'd be dreaming when I was awake I
can't really explain what the hell was
going on but I'd wake up in the morning
and felt like you were on opioids dude
that's what was
going I'd wake up in the morning and
felt like I did a good job or a bad job
in in the night which obviously doesn't
make sense so she had seen that I wasn't
looking my normal self and she's
messaged a group saying or messag Robbie
saying it looks look like Wills on some
like strong painkillers like what's
going on I think that's when the penny
dropped with the crew and they were like
oh [__] so Robbie didn't even know no
Robbie knew I was doing it but he wasn't
I think he hadn't thought about it the
way I I hadn't thought about it like we
just we were doing
it unconsciously it was just a decision
I I told them I was going to do it and
they were fine with it they weren't
concerned in any way shape or form on
day nine they gave my brother the job of
telling me so I think it was a I think
it was about halfway through the day
when I was about to have a nap I didn't
usually have naps on this one but I
needed one when I woke up he was like
you're not having coding anymore and the
funny thing was growing up my mom being
a nurse we would if we had like a
headache or a cold or whatever the last
thing she'd want to do is give us any
kind of pharmaceutical drug it'd be if
you really needed it whereas I had the
Quick Fix mentality where I was like
can't I just have something that's going
to
like now that's what we want as human
beings so that's what a lot of us have
learned to be like so when he said you
can't take it anymore I was like relax
Mom cuz that's what I'd have usually
have said when she was around but as
soon as I stopped taking it I actually
started taking CBD oil instead it was
crazy that night I had the first proper
sleep of the whole challenge I woke up
in the morning and all the inflammation
that had been storing up and like my
knees and ankles had flushed out I was
myself again which was the main thing
and then from that point on from day 9
to 16 when I finished I ran over 60 M A
Day mhm so that was a big lesson for me
I haven't I maybe have taken ibuprofen a
couple times but ever since then it's
been very few and far between I can
probably count on one hand when I've
taken a pharmaceutical drug between then
which was yeah four years ago and today
today yeah so when you did that you'd
only been running how long at that point
like not long like you're back you're
you're going back to back 60 mile days
and I know you've said in your adamant
that like you're not a talented Runner
and you know all the like but you know
that's that's impressive especially
without years of building a base and
learning about how to do this kind of
stuff I think is I come from an athletic
background anyway like I've always been
playing sport since I was a kid to
before that moment playing rugby
semi-professionally so there was like a
foundation there to build from but yeah
I lean more on like in in that space of
time for me I just I wanted to it was
like acceptable self harm I wanted to
hurt myself and I needed a way of doing
it without raising too many alarm bells
and running really far actually started
raising a lot of alarm bells for gram my
dad but for everyone else it was like
but you can get away with it you can
certainly hide your pain behind great
Feats of athleticism for sure so that's
what that was about
[Music]
yeah the other thing about you is that
you know you're a you're not a bean pole
like you're a topheavy dude you're
[__] cut like ripped strong strong
upper body and that is one of the other
things that sort of distinguishes you
from what people imagine when they think
of people that run great distances they
tend to be very slight in their build
but strength training has always been a
key component
in your
preparation and um I think if I had to
guess I would suspect that it
contributes to your
durability um and makes you more injury
resistant I know Robbie has even said to
me like man after you know spending all
this time with William like I'm going to
the gym like I'm he's trying to like
bulk up now you know he's looking good
yeah as a result and I know you have a
whole like training program and and and
all of that so how do you think about um
the you know the kind of unorthodox
approach to physical training like aside
from just putting the miles in what
you're doing in the gym and how that
contributes to your performances I think
it's I think it's massive especially for
me um I think having a bit extra muscle
mass is not really going to help if I'm
trying to run a super fast Marathon but
in terms of being dur durable and not
breaking down I think it I think the
proofs in the pudding like what I've
shown I can do being a a bigger athlete
or whatever whatever label you want to
put on it um I do I generally think it
makes me very dur durable um and a lot
of the exercises we're doing in the
training programs that we have is all
like single leg based um loaded
everything's in like a a lot of
movements in a split squat so we're
we're trying to get a lot of the
weighted positions in running spe
specific um areas as well so all of
those bits on me that used to break down
quicker than anything glutes hamstrings
everything around there as soon as I
started strengthening those areas then
that negated the the the rate at which I
broke down mhm so I'd say it's such a
huge part of my huge part of my training
and will always be the foundation for it
and then I'll add running on top so in
your leadup to the transon what did the
the functional strength gym workout
routine schedule look like always three
times a week um there'd be an element of
pretty much everything in it so there
there'd be legs on all three of those
days but then there'd be some upper body
stuff again in in a split squat thing so
we're training a lot of core at the same
time making sure the Lo the load is
going to challenge you in those those
running positions um and some of it's
aesthetic as well cuz it's just it's
what I've it's what I've always done and
I have to enjoy what I'm doing to want
to carry on doing it well you got to be
catwalk ready
too big for the catwalk at the drop Dude
too big for the catwalk as well that's
why I watch the shows now instead yeah
did you like where did the modeling
stuff take you did you get like are you
still doing that every now and again
uhhuh um yeah it's few and far between
like I'm not going to do a day in the
studio because I just don't want to
anymore but yeah if it's a like not
cataloges but not catwalk either yeah
just like campaign stuff so yeah I've
spent some time in New York I've been
done some stuff over here Italy France
Switzerland I've kind of that was a a
fun part of my life like I really
enjoyed it traveling around the world
doing this kind of stuff but at the at
the same time it was just another thing
in life that was going okay that to the
outside world looked looked better than
it was so doing all this traveling being
in La New York whatever as a 20
something going back to my small town
everyone would think like they were just
like wow what you're doing so amazing
I'm like yeah I'm racking up credit card
bills just like living the life and
yeah living paycheck to paycheck so yeah
it's one of those things that looks
amazing on the outside and so there's a
lot of [__] on social media but
sometimes is still a
challenge so you do the J of Gro run you
learn a few things along the way uh and
where does the motivation to step it up
from there come from just continuing to
build on this enthusiasm for pushing
your limits yeah I think that cemented
where I was in life and where I wanted
to go with it um like you said it's like
chasing the dragon again it's once
you've got a taste for it immediately
afterwards you're like nah I'm never
going to do that again and then a few
days later I was literally figuring out
what I was going to do next now I didn't
know what that was going to be um and
afterwards I was still pretty destroyed
so I was going to take some time off but
the first thing I started looking at
doing was running a marathon in every
country in Europe so there's 45
countries in Europe but then coid
happened mhm so travel obviously stopped
so I had to think of I had to think of
another thing to do that meant I could
stay in the UK even though I wanted to
like expand a lot of what I do in life
is visiting new places and doing new
things but I was restricted so a random
Google search I was like in the US you
have 50 states everyone knows it
everyone's proud of it in the UK no one
knows how many we have counties how many
counties there are like if you asked
anyone on the street they would probably
be like 25 34 like no one knows so I
just Googled it and there were 48 um it
being close to the 45 countries of
Europe I was like okay well that make
sense that I'll do it next because
there's not going to be limitations on
travel like I might have to figure out
if if Co comes back or if we get shut
down in any kind of way I'm going to
have to figure out what it looks like
but it was the best option at the time
and it came two years after I finished
the length of the UK so yeah the second
one was 48 marathons in the 48 counties
of England in 30 days and
ironically um people think it's the most
amazing thing when they hear it and for
me of all the things you've done that's
the thing it stands out because it's so
easy to understand running the length of
the UK what who knows it's 875 miles but
no one's going to split that into
marathons but 48 marathons in 30 days
very easy to understand and whilst it
was amazing I was kind of annoyed at the
end of it cuz it didn't didn't get me
anywhere close to what the run of the UK
did not even close interesting and you
made like a documentary out of that yeah
and it was it was cool and it was a a
nice it was a very good experience to
I've definitely ticked off running in
the UK now it's definitely done but it
was a nice way to see that you could run
the the perimeter of the circumference
I'm not doing that I think did Nick
butter try to do that do you know Nick
butter yeah yeah yeah yeah I think he
was doing I think he did do it I think
he did yeah yeah cuz there was also the
guy I can't remember remember the rebel
guy that swam around it uh Ross Edy
insane yeah yeah no I'm not do talked
about that afterwards that was crazy
yeah but like the last one which was
which was
interesting the 48th marathon i' pbd on
my fastest marathon of all time I it was
at London the official London Marathon
which was a very special way to finish
and I did a
306 which was at the time my fastest
marathon but that showed how much had
left in the tank cuz it was so
regimented it was either 26.2 m a day or
56 or 50 52.4 mhm and I was having
enough rest in between to just kind of
go and do it to pop off your PB on the
on the very end of that whole experience
to bookend it that's impressive but
that's how that's how my head works at
the same time I had to I still had to
leave it all out there like I had to I
had to feel like it was it obviously
still was a challenge and I had some low
days but for the most part it was it was
just kind of like clockwork I just did
it mhm but you finished that feeling
like oh I haven't even really
approximated the the extent of my
capabilities yeah after the transcon
run I I think you probably still feel
that way yeah right yeah like here's the
thing watching you run across the
country and watching the videos that
that went up every every every week and
all the social media posts
um you made it look I'm not going to say
easy certainly didn't look easy but
there was a lightness to most of it
there were low moments of course but for
the most part it all seemed kind of
breezy yeah and it felt like as hard as
it might have felt to you from an the
way that you kind of reflected that
experience outward you were always very
conscious of keeping it positive trying
to make it fun um making sure that the
crew was happy and by the time you
completed it it it was pretty clear to
me like oh this guy's got a lot more to
give here like you it's not like you
just collapsed you know in Central Park
and that was the most that you could
possibly do like it all seemed well
within your capacity it's it's very
interesting because it's totally the
unknown like the 4830 was 1250 miles
this was close to 3100 so I was entering
a totally new space and obviously when
we started out we were aiming for 64
days it was 50 m a day it was like um it
was a good a good thing to aim for mhm
but at the same time I still had no idea
what I was what I was capable of but
there was still a point in my mind that
was like my ESA visa for the US you get
90 days and we did Robbie speed project
before and set up all the vehicles so I
knew I had
7 Days extra I could have got to 71 days
and I'd have had to pissed off
immediately otherwise your government
wouldn't be very happy with me but yeah
it was it was very much the unknown and
it was also hard to push myself as hard
as I did on drag Land's End one because
I've come further as an athlete but
secondly because it's so much bigger
there's risk that if you push too hard
at the start then that might cause an
injury or cause you to have to slow down
or go less but yeah my my week one was
the lowest mileage week of all of them
other than the last one cuz I finished I
finished on the Saturday but yeah it was
it was an amazing experience but yeah
there was still those questions at the
end of how do I get it's it's
interesting that I want self-destruct
that's what I'm seeking but along the
way I also figured out how I what I need
to do to do that what was the
preparation and training like leading up
to running across America we didn't know
it was actually going to happen until I
think it was late January I started in
April so the first thing I did was I
went on a 5we training camp in Cape Town
I was there for December cuz my friends
live there anyway and all I did was
continue my strength training as usual
and try to up the mileage so I was doing
anywhere between 50 and 70 miles a week
which compared to 300 not a lot it's not
a lot even in like a a marathon runners
regim if you're actually very good at it
you're going to be 100 mile weaking sure
and I was not but that was more a
foundation to build from so I did that
came back for a bit and then when we got
the green light I decided to go out and
spend some time with Robbie and he was
in cider in Colorado now so that's at
7200 ft um the highest point on transcon
is Angel Fire which is in New Mexico at
9,000 ft and fortunately there's a
mountain range right by where Roby lives
so we did some I was there for 10 days
and we we did we did 140 mile week that
week so closer to it but yeah generally
my mileages weren't that high but again
there's I don't know if it's I don't
know if it's self-confidence or me just
trying to get away with doing less than
I should but the way I looked at it was
you can't train to run 370 odd miles a
week you can get a little bit along the
way but if you if you go too far then
you may as well be doing the challenge
or you're going to injure yourself so
asides from my strength training which
is locked in I just built up mileage
gradually did some elevation training
and then
started I mean I don't think that that
sounds irresponsible at all like you
have to have some form of a base but you
want to go into the experience as fresh
as possible and understanding that
you're going to build into it and
develop Fitness as you go and if you're
conservative on the front end of it your
body will adapt right the mistakes get
made when you show up overtrained or not
rested enough or you're too aggressive
early on and you end up with some kind
of injury like Ned Brockman you know in
in Australia right like he has that epic
you know issue that almost derails the
whole thing um talk about a guy who went
into something before he knew what he
was getting into he's my kind of guy
yeah I know right um uh so I mean it
sounds smart to go in fit in that way
and to have an adequate amount of
confidence to do it yeah and I've got
I've got more self-confidence in knowing
myself through doing this as well so
sure when I do something next time like
I'll increase the mileage and training
but it worked at the end of the day at
the end of the day it worked so yeah so
the idea was 50 mil a day that will take
you 64 days to cross the US you end up
doing it in 50
5 actually 56 right if you if you adjust
for the time changes right you were
right on that edge there yeah the
hardcore is going to say it was
56 5 55 right
um uh and it seemed like you you had
some low moments but you got stronger as
as you went
along yeah and that's there's a lot of
Kudos that needs to be given to the team
as well when you're out there
literally the only thing I had to be
worried about was running that's the
best well running and wiping my ass is
the only two things I did basically so
when you have that confidence in the
people around you it makes you be able
to push yourself to your perceived
limits will push further than you
normally would because I'm quite I'm
quite a controlling person in life
usually but the trust I had in the
people around me Robbie and Pete Ree and
James doing the content as well allowed
me to just concentrate on the running
side of things so yeah a lot of credit
goes to them but also I remember them
saying the start was between Robbie
Ballinger and Peter John the first few
weeks they they almost wanted to hold me
back like a dog on the Chain which which
worked well because I was I was still
going further than I needed to anyway so
every with every week I was doing I had
this cushion just kept getting bigger
and bigger and bigger until we got to a
space where it was like okay now we're
confident that you probably won't derail
or you're far enough along the way now
let's push and see how much how much
faster you can go in the 64 days and
obvious obviously we did which was which
was amazing and yeah if you'd have told
me at the start that it' been 56 55 days
or whatever I'd have been like something
would have had to have gone really right
for that to happen like it was outside
of my yeah you so far eclipsed the goal
that you set for yourself yeah it was an
interesting daily schedule breakdown
also so the idea was every day you would
get up get out as quickly as you could
out onto the road and Bank 30 and then
take a break and then a new calm nap
right we talk about newal um and then
finish the day with uh like an easier 20
with like some of the pressure off right
and then once you completed that you
would do a Beer Mile y did you do the
Beer Mile every day every day other than
maybe two or three talk about the the
rationale behind that the Beer Mile is
to celebrate the day and what you've
done and it's a a disconnect from what
you're doing and you're getting an extra
mile so may sound stupid like drinking a
beer it's probably not the best things
for recovery
but for me so much of so much of it is
the mental side of things and also the
period in when you're resting to
disconnect yourself from what you're
doing and try and take any moment of
normality as you can and the BMR was the
start of that so it would be a fun
moment in the day it' be something for
me to look forward to at all points as I
said I would walk I would walk from a
mile with a beer with one of the crew
just chat [__] and have a good time and
then finish and feel really really drunk
at that at that point one beer will hit
you pretty hard and yeah it was the
ultimate disconnect and then I'd get
back to our van I'd have a shower and
then we'd have dinner together as a crew
and that was another really big thing
where you might say well you shouldn't
have had the beer M and once you got
back you should have had dinner and bed
and gone to sleep immediately but it was
it so good for morale for me and I think
for everyone else and you can't you
can't understand how powerful that is
over a big period of time to have those
moments of normality and what it can
actually do and if I feel good I'm going
to run further simple as right but if
you're just going to hit that day's goal
that extra time spent doing that I think
is sort of a you know a genius technique
to reboot the mental health aspect of
this whole thing like the iron Cowboy
when he gets asked like is it physical
is it mental what's he's like it's 100%
physical and it's 100% mental right and
we understand the physical piece but I
don't know that many people optimize for
the mental piece because they are
focused on you get the day done you get
into the van you get fed as quickly as
possible you you know you wash yourself
or whatever and you get to sleep as
quickly as you can because you need that
sleep right but to stay fresh day after
day after day with the routine and just
the kind of bludgeoning you know
schedule that you were keeping to have a
little bit of levity and to kind of feel
connected to your crew members and allow
them space to enjoy themselves with you
feels like it's something that would and
in your case did like pay great
dividends yeah it was otherwise it' just
be [__] basically all the time all time
like it's it's hard enough what you're
doing running 13 14 hours a day whatever
but just to have that moment of like a
celebration it just it makes it just
makes everything feel good like the
thought I don't know if it's being giv
something to look forward to British
whatever but the thought of like having
a beer with your mates it's one of the
one of the best feelings in the world so
I got to experience that every day did
you ever have a day where you did the
Beer Mile but then you felt good and
then you wanted to run after that yeah
there were there was a couple there was
a couple of times there was one where I
I had to run further and I I can't
remember why I think it's cuz I messed
up where the where the campsite was for
the night they' told me one thing and I
was obviously like Pete would go ahead
and start preparing the van and the the
meal and whatever um and I got the
distance wrong so I think I had to do
like another three or whatever but I was
I was fine with that I was skipping down
the road what was the the lowest moment
or the hardest piece it was day 17 it
was the only day I didn't reach my
distance that did 47 A2 miles and it was
kind of a it was kind of a mashup of
things one of the one of the things that
was more on like the physical side was
it was the first day we'd fallen off on
nutrition nutrition was is such a big
thing you can't do you can't do this
kind of thing without it as we were
saying every 6 miles I'd see the crew
I'd reup my bottles I was taking this
stuff called scratch I didn't know about
before but even from that alone I was
getting 20 I think it was 2400 calories
I was aiming for 7 7,000 so a lot of my
calories came from just what I was
drinking which kind of tastes like
slightly flavored water but on this
particular day when when you're in these
things for me anyway I don't have an
appetite I can eat a lot but if you ask
me what I want to eat I'm going to be
like I don't know cuz I've been eating
everything all day for the past two
weeks already so there's nothing that's
like shouting out to me and on day 17
along the way when I got into a stop
they' be like what do you want and I'd
be like I don't know anything and I'd
just grab snacks rather than we trying
to go really Whole Food based as
possible that's where I got really good
energy from and and I felt good and this
particular day from about halfway I was
just I'd go in and have some crisps and
some nuts or like a bar or whatever and
that really fell off um but also there
had been like a buildup of this guy who
even before I started had been messaging
me like asking me about what I was doing
and questioning some of the things I was
saying about it um and it had just been
getting more heated and more heated and
whilst it didn't really affect me
personally what what he was saying
basically when it before it started I'd
put out that I was attempting or I was
going to become the fastest Englishman
to run across
America um he'd looked at my power of 10
which is some website that Runners look
at shows all your fastest times events
you've done Etc and he said that it
sounds really good what you're doing but
an athlete of your stature should
probably be looking to do it in 82 days
which would be really
respectable and also the wording on your
van will become is very insulting to the
guy that currently has a record Bruce
Tuller anyway I looked at that message
and I was just like [__] whatever
mate like I'm not I'm not going to give
you a response um and then he proceeded
to hit up everyone involved in the
challenge in one way or another
including
sponsors um he says he said like I was
faking it said the most the funniest
thing he actually said was I was Raising
half a million dollars for cancer Chari
is that I was going to
steal so the guy's a little bit
deluded um but he'd obviously been
messaging a lot and it got to Robbie the
most Robbie Robbie took it quite
personally cuz he was basically
questioning not just me but himself and
everyone involved in the challenge so
we've been talking about ignoring it
bringing it up like publicizing this guy
had been harassing us blah blah blah and
on this day in particular
I'd kind of been more in a [__] you mode
about it like I was I was angry because
it was affecting Robbie so that
alongside the nutrition falling off
alongside it being quite an emotional
day the day before I was thinking about
my mom a lot it was a beautiful moment
but I was quite emotionally fatigued as
well just kind of compounded to me
having one [__] day but in the same vein
when I got to 47 and A2 miles St 17 I
was already I don't know what was that I
was
probably 50 mil ahead of where I was
supposed to be anyway so I just had this
very Frank feeling in my mind I was like
I'm so far ahead the fact that I'm going
to stop now and not get to my daily
Target for the first time is fine and
let a go yeah and the next day I came
out and eclipsed 52 and a half so it's
like I still made it but it was T it was
tough in the moment to to deal with
there was there was a lot going on but
yeah that was definitely the lowest
point but in the grand scheme of low
moments on an epic adventure like that
there's a lot of things that could have
gone wrong that didn't like that's not
that low of a moment right it was your
low but being so far ahead and then
bouncing back and then working your way
back into the black you know more and
more and more as you headed into New
York I mean there's a momentum to that
yeah there's always going to be low
moments on this kind of thing but as you
said earlier like all I ever want to
project is like the positive end of
things I don't I don't want to go out
there and be complaining about [__] all
the time which is very very easy to do
but it doesn't make me feel it doesn't
make me feel good like if I'm out there
looking like I'm having somewhat of a
laugh or like enjoying the moments it's
going to be it's going to be a lot
easier for me to deal with it's such a
big arduous task
but just life man like try try and enjoy
the little things
like I was I was always very conscious
that I was so lucky to be there doing it
like it's not every day you get to do
that opportunity and raise money for
charity do it for the reasons you're
doing it and being surrounded by some of
my best friends in the world having this
[__] adventure to talk about for 50
years when I'm in the pub and have
nothing else to talk about as far as the
controversy goes so this guy who was
sort of a Protegé of the record holder
guy who actually wasn't the record
holder guy right there was another guy
who had gone faster yeah so there's it's
probably our fault but when we were
looking there's not this isn't very well
documented when we were deciding like
how fast I was going to do it in I said
originally I wanted to do it in 66 days
don't know why it just sounded good it
was close to 50 Mi and then I was like I
wonder who's who's the like we knew um
Pete kck's the fastest to do I'm not
getting close to that guy he was like 42
days or something I think it was 77
miles a day like sure I did better than
expected but I'm know that's to be from
my point of view that's the only record
that
matters but I needed something for aim
for to aim for and so I asked Robbie
like do you know who the fastest
European is do you know who the fastest
Brit person British person is so we
found out the fastest Brit or at least
this is what it said was Bruce teller um
it was 65 days so I was like okay great
let's shoot for 64 makes it a round
number we've s since learned that there
was a guy that power walked it in was it
days yeah he power walked it and he went
from like the fastest route is to go
from San Francisco to New York yeah I
think it's more like 2900 miles so he'd
done that in the '90s
but again it was just something to aim
for for me but this this irked this guy
cuz he was he was close with the guy who
he you guys both thought held the record
yeah and he's a running historian and
yeah a running well also like sort of a
uh a running sleuth who has committed
himself to outing people that he think
thinks are are sort of unfairly claiming
titles that they didn't earn right and
he does this by going on message boards
like let's run or whatever and and
creating a curfuffle and creating
momentum and and interest in other
people in what you're doing and so there
was a little bit of a ground swell of
people who were like what's going I mean
I got DMs like people were like you need
to look into this and I was like listen
man I know Robbie I know ree I know I
don't know you that well but I know you
well enough and I just just the fact
that like Robbie is there like there's
no [__] way like Robbie has a zero
tolerance policy for anything that isn't
in Integrity I know that about him
there's just no [__] way that
anything
is untour about this or going sideways
so but just the fact that people were
pinging me about it you know I sort of
looked into it more than I probably
would have liked to and then the fact
that this guy actually flies from the UK
and shows up like in Oklahoma right yeah
determined to root you out yeah as soon
as we've arrived so we' literally
crossed the border and also Shelly
Robbie's wife had just arrived as well
so we knew he was coming
I didn't know exactly at what point he I
think he' I think he'd put in one of the
things that he put some really lame
[__] message like about James Bond I
can't remember what the exact quote was
but that he was coming to like he said
he was James Bond and I was the bad guy
which is kind of funny um but yeah he
arrived and obviously at as soon as he
arrived there's some bitterness there's
some Choice words shared um but we
understand he's going to be around for a
while so like what ever um and I was
just finishing that day and I think it
was it was a good day I think that might
have been my biggest it might have been
70 Mi that day or at least it was
definitely a 60 mile day so it' been a
big one and then the next morning he
shows up at the start and then drives a
mile ahead while I run a mile he's he
comes out of his car and he's he starts
running backwards and forwards we don't
know why he was doing this if he was
just trying to log his own miles or
trying to figure out what his heart rate
looked like compared to the ones he'd
seen online of mine cuz this is his
whole thing like your heart rate data
was out of whack from his perspective
were you wearing a chest strap or was it
wrist heart rate no so I started off
this is classic me as well when I when I
started I didn't have a watch so I
borrowed p p Gar so you're doing trans G
you're not even like wearing a a Garmin
or a or coros or anything no but I did
have a whoop on the whole time which has
been great because they've published all
of my rate data they it's not a GPS
tracker no so that was his issue we had
a Tracker in the van and really that was
for entertainment purposes so you could
log on the website and see where we were
but I wasn't wearing a Tracker I didn't
see why I needed to so the so the heart
rate data that that activated him was
going off of the whoop no it was off of
so in the end I had a choros but it was
the beginning it was the scarman watch
apparently it was wrong um and had
looked back into the past at my juggle
effort as well and other runs I've done
basically called all of it [__] um
yeah his main thing his main thing was
the heart rate and when you were when
you had the coros did you have a chest
strap or you're going off wrist heart
rate with that wrist again so anything
wrist heart rate is [__] like it
doesn't matter what watch you're wearing
or what device like it's just not an
accurate way to to track heart rate I
agree if you're on an ECG you're going
to get it right but and even from
another point of view like was his mate
Bruce wearing a heart rate monitored
does anyone from the past have data or
anything to show that they truly did
anything who knows man I mean exactly
the thing is obviously he had some kind
of relationship with with that guy and
you making an audacious statement got
him energized right and then on top of
that you being you and not looking like
you know what people expect you to look
like and not you know coming from a
certain sort of tradition probably was
sort of fuel on the fire to all of that
you know one of the weirdest things that
happened out there as well um I don't
know if it was on the second or third
day he was there but as I said he'd been
driving a mile coming out and running
like back and forth and then getting
back in his car sometimes he'd like give
me a wave after a while he was actually
being really friendly which was kind of
weird but one of the times I just
knocked on his window and said do you
want to like walk with me for a minute
and just talk like there's no cameras
around I don't have my phone or whatever
like you just want to talk about it and
my purpose for doing that was I want I
was just I wanted to understand where
his where he was coming from so I was
like do you know the reason why I
actually run and he's like yes it's cuz
your mother passed away I have a similar
story my mom did too when I was 20 I was
like oh my God like I'm so sorry about
that and he said no it was a good thing
she was um she was an addict she was
mentally unstable and basically said he
hated her so that kind of that's a whole
new dimension that's a whole new
dimension and it it made me I I felt
sorry for him for feeling it way whether
it was just or not but then I also
understood that asides from me not
looking or acting like most
Runners my reason for doing this kind of
stuff is fueled from the love I have
from of my mom and everything she gave
me in life and the power that comes from
that whereas his story which is somewhat
similar in terms of age and losing his
mom was he was happy about and he hated
her now someone's doing something
raising up that person I can understand
why he might look at that and go well
definitely not understand it for for
another reason
so you weren't reared in a tradition of
ultr running you're more you know
somebody who came up in a different
strain of of the fitness world and as
somebody who has a presence on social
media and Instagram and also knows how
to provide sponsor value through the
efforts that you're making like I think
that um the way in which you represented
newal was like really of value to that
brand and other people who are trying to
get products and services on board to
support them in whatever goal they're
trying to accomplish should take note
because most athletes will approach a
brand and say will you give me money or
will you give me Product I'm doing this
really hard thing and I'll put your logo
on my shirt whereas the way that you did
it was almost like branded content like
the newom the use of newom was integral
to the whole journey itself and telling
the story about how that worked within
the context of how you were approaching
each day became seamless with the effort
itself in a way that I would imagine
really benefited that brand and was also
organic and authentic to what you were
trying to do well I I certainly hope
that it boosted everything they're doing
because it was totally integral to what
I was doing and I would never push
something I didn't believe in anyway and
the reason I had confidence in it before
this already was ironically again this
is the story of my my running journey
and eventually running across the US is
so connected to here but after I did JN
great the land's end I went to New York
I think I had work there and when Robbie
finished his run he went to this place
called recover doesn't exist anymore
since Co but they had infrared saers
norm tech boots that kind of stuff but
they also had newom when it was this
$5,000 medical grade device so you you
put these I don't know put these
stickers on your neck that were attached
to electrodes still had the headphones
and IM mask and it did the the same
thing but that was my first experience
of it and then by the time I did 4830 it
was then in an application on your phone
and part of the reason why 4830 went so
well I believe was because I was using
newom so at that point it wasn't like a
sponsored deal I just used them anyway
and after every every Marathon I'd
finish I'd have some food and then I'd
do newom for anywhere between 30 minutes
and 60 Minutes in the in the on the
journey from going from one County to
the next to start the next one or if I
had one one day I'd finish and do the
same thing and I'd listen to it
overnight but for me what newal does is
it's like hitting the reset button on
any day so it's neuroacoustic software
basically takes your brain frequency
from awake stressed whatever down into
the the lower frequencies which are REM
sleep deep sleep at the beginning it's
sort of like a meditative state that it
gives you just by pressing a button
listening to their binal beats and
shutting your eyes and basically having
Darkness um and in doing like a
30-minute track it's like getting 3
hours of normal sleep it's that's what
it does at the touch of the but button
brings you down so I had such a good
experience on
4830 that whether they were sponsoring
the run across America or not I was
still going to split up my day in a
similar way to what I did on 48th a like
I had confidence in it so as you said
earlier anywhere from mile 30 to 42 it'd
be a big stop I'd come in have a proper
my biggest of the day other than dinner
and then I'd narm for 30 minutes and
that would take an hour basically I'd
have a timer I wanted to that big stop
to be an hour Max and the way I
facilitated that in my head as well was
every every other stop between the six
miles I didn't get in and really stop it
was more of a walk through switch out
bottles mm have food and take it on the
go as quickly as I could cuz if I'm
doing if I'm do just just say 60 miles
for example if I'm doing 60 miles I've
got nine stops if I took 10 minutes at
each of those it's an hour and a half if
I took 7 and a half it's like an hour so
if I didn't do if I didn't stop at those
stops it gave me that big one in the
middle as as free MH and I doubled down
on that by using newom as well right and
you get this full reboot so basically as
I understand it um it's it's like this
binaural audio that
um activates your brain in a certain way
but it also is different from different
binaural beats applications in that the
the the beats are always changing right
because your brain will will will adapt
to it over time and then it loses its
efficacy yeah so that's that their
technology is patented so as you said
it's always slightly evolving even
though I'm not that intelligent and it's
hard for me to get this across my brain
would pick up if it was listening to the
same patterns over and over again so it
basically is always effective uhhuh it's
uh and you are very effective as an
ambassador of that because I Robbie was
singing its Praises forever and they
sent me a kit a long time ago and it sat
on my desk forever and I never used it
and then I'm seeing you use it and I was
like I'm okay F I'm going to do this and
it is like it's really helpful I just
feel the best thing about it other than
like feeling I've hit the reset button
like it's a new day is I feel so calm
like waking up in a stressful
environment thinking I've got 20 more
miles to run cuz and I've already ran
mhm 35 or whatever usually that wouldn't
feel that good but I would wake up and
just be ultimately at peace with things
and just it'd be like okay I've got this
left to do there's a lot of hours of
daylight left like let's just go and do
it and it was yeah incredible really um
one of the things that that's
interesting about you is given the fact
that you you do come from a different
set of Life Experiences you have the
ability to connect with and communicate
with an audience that lives out you know
far outside of The Cloister ad ultra
running Community I think I even said to
you like you should get Vogue magazine
to like sponsor the run or whatever and
like do dispatches for like a fashion
magazine you know like because that
would I actually think that's cool
because it would
introduce this world and your experience
to people who or aren't seeking that
kind of information
you in
a and
interes as as not a mouthpiece but as a
living example of you know finding a
healthier way to live but also being
somebody who enjoys those types of
things in life yeah it's interesting how
many people in my life and in my other
world have got into running with it be a
marathon or even ultramarathons as well
so that's what I think that's my
favorite thing about doing this it's
when someone comes out with you and
achieves something for themselves that
they never thought they were going to do
it was really apparent on JN great
salon's end I had 11 friends and family
members come out and run either a
marathon or an ultra marathon having
never run a 5k before because they're in
a space where they feel like they're
helping you and you're obviously pretty
thrashed already it's an environment
where other people can Excel with
knowing that they're going to and being
part of that Journey or popping cherries
as I as I like to call it is it's it's
incredibly beautiful and you've obvious
you've of almost given them a gift as
well of being like well I just did that
kind of off the bat what more can I do
now and it's it's been cool to see
friends and family members push
themselves in in this way as well yeah
this ground swell of running enthusiasm
amidst the fashionista yes it's it's
crazy but it's it's cool it's very cool
um what was it like as you as you were
coming into New York City and there was
more and more attention you know on what
you were doing and excitement about the
impending finish and having people kind
of come out to run alongs side of you
yeah it was it's very special because
when you're out there and you're in your
own world like sure you'll see you get
messages and stuff but when you see real
human beings being there and explaining
to you how you may have helped all their
Journey or they've been through
something similar is is very humbling
and also gives you some more positive
reinforcement for what you're doing so
yeah there was I don't know like 50
people at the end waiting on the George
Washington Bridge to run in with me we
pissed off a lot of cyclists on the way
in and I do not apologize to that oh
come on no I'm a cyclist too so but yeah
it was it's it's it's crazy it's
emotional it's it's a shared experience
there that's what the the best things in
life are so so yeah I I understand that
people would have got something from
doing that um yeah it's it's hard to
it's hard to basically take that many
like compliments as you go I'm not very
good at it I'm just I'm just doing what
I'm doing I don't think too highly of
myself at all the time so yeah it's a
it's one I actually feel kind of
uncomfortable with when so many people
are there and wanting to be a part of it
cuz I I you feel like you have to you
have to take responsibility for making
sure that they're enjoying themselves
while you're also trying to achieve this
goal yeah somewhat and cuz it's I cuz
it's about me I know I have I know I
have to do it but when something's so
much about me I don't actually really
like it I prefer Christmas to my
birthday put it that way I'd prefer
sharing everyone having a good time then
yeah it been all about me but comes with
the territory I guess when I had Robbie
here to talk about his transone and I
asked
him what so some of his most U memorable
moments were
um he wanted to talk about the Navajo
Nation so talk a little bit about your
experience traversing that part of of
the country incredibly beautiful there
was just a different feeling in the air
from even when I
arrived um very calm very beautiful and
just the the people make the place right
um there was a lot more interest all of
a sudden like people would stop and see
the Vans and ask what was going on I had
people running with me um when I run I
face traffic it's just a a smart thing
to do for safety if you can see the
traffic coming towards you you can see
that it's not going to move around you
then you can get out of the way but I'd
always put my hand up to thank someone
that went past and there it wasn't like
a a nod of an acknowledgement or a
finger it would be like like a big wave
they were yeah everyone there was was so
welcoming I had guys come out out and
run with me and I had this guy Jackie
came out one day he was a runner from
the local era and he he he bought me a
bracelet so I wore that wore that for
the whole time but yeah it's it's it's
different it's different to anywhere
else I've been in the world and I'm
looking forward to getting back there
what was it like when you finally
finished in Central Park the whole day
was like a dream from waking up to being
there to finishing everything looked and
felt different it was almost like
watching my watching myself in a dream
or being part of it it was a release of
emotion at the end as you can
imagine um and it was it's probably
probably the best time of my life to be
honest it was it was it was insane and I
had so many more people there at that
time like my brother was there my dad
was there so many of my friends had
flown over and yeah to get there at the
end and people running with me it
was it's to totally surreal totally
surreal it's crazy that you your plan
was to do 64 and you finish in
5556 um that's [__] Elite dude like I
think only like five or so people in the
last decade have done it more quickly
than that yeah it's not that well
documented so
know it's like who [__] cares like
honestly you know but it is I just want
for the audience to understand like
that's it's not like
not that many people run across America
but most of them that do aren't doing it
at this pace and just for context like
that's very fast what you did very few
people have done it more quickly than
that um but we're still talking about a
12-minute pace yeah that was what that's
what I was shooting for yeah yeah it's
it's that's 5 miles an hour and in terms
of what that looks like over a day
asides from taking my hour break in the
middle to get to 50 Mi I knew if I did 5
m hour it's 10 hours think how much rest
you have after that
so my relationship with time and Pace
changed a lot you don't know how much
you're going to get into mathematics
when you're out there but that's what I
was living by I was living by the pace
on my watch obviously I was kind of
present with what I was doing but I was
I was so into time distance splits like
on on another level and also
understanding just how far or how much
you can do in a day 24 hours is long
time I was running for 133 and after 55
days I'd crossed America which is
absolutely insane and still hard for me
to still hard for me to process but I
don't think we I don't think we give
ourselves enough credit or or enough
leeway to push ourselves to our limits
or find out what's possible even in
doesn't have to be in endurance it can
be in business or the Arts whatever
but yeah I feel very I feel very lucky
in those moments that I get to explore a
new space of of seeing what I am capable
of doing you have this Mantra that you
even have on your socks which is emotion
is energy yeah so what does that mean
why is that your kind of
Talisman well from the the beginning
obviously I said I
was very upset and angry when my mom
passed away which makes a lot of sense
um but for me heightened emotion being
good or bad can be channeled towards
energy a positive output so if you think
about the most basic way I can think of
it is when you're a kid if you
imagine the H like the happiest day of
your life like if you got that really
good Christmas present you got a BMX
bike outside like how much excitement
you had at that time and how much like
energy you had that can be Channel
towards something on the flip side of
the coin when you were super angry you
maybe didn't get the BMX bike or when
you're a kid and something bad happened
you'd go up to your room and you'd punch
the [__] out of your pillow like again
that's that's energy from emotion but
the best thing that's ever happened to
me is to understand that and be able to
channel it and do you feel like you've
gone from a place where at one time the
emotions were controlling you or
channeling you in a direction that was
sort of out of your control to a place
where now you're the master of that and
more in charge of how you deploy that
emotion in the direction that you want
to move definitely and what was how did
you make that transition from anger
grief confusion to one of you know
purpose and inspiration quite honestly I
think I had to destroy myself to rebuild
myself up which was what JN great Salan
end was I was I was so seeking that
self-destruction that I had to go
through through it to I didn't know what
the outcome was going to be but I had to
bury myself to then realize those
lessons of okay you're still going to
have these emotions at certain times I
think going through what I went through
and dealing it with the way I did even
though it was maybe negative has then
become something very positive so now
now it's more like of a celebration as I
said I'm still going to get sad and
upset at certain times in life but
it's it sounds strange but Mom passing
away gave me purpose for the first time
in my life and purpose is the best thing
on planet Earth to achieve anything if
you and what is and and how would you
define that purpose for yourself the
purpose for me again asides from making
my mom's death mean something
it's finding the line and then Crossing
it it's finding that that new space of
self-discovery of what you never thought
was possible becomes possible and then
the best thing about that is it's a
never- Ending Story because once you've
crossed that line and got up from the
next step on the ladder the ceiling
raises exactly the ceiling raises and
it's something we probably hear all the
time but exper experiencing it for
yourself changes you on a cellular level
beyond anything you could have just gone
to
therapy say that to you I got told this
and I was offer it but yeah um I'm glad
I've gone on the path of having figured
the stuff out because life is amazing
and my favorite times are probably the
worst physical times it's it's growth
and doesn't matter how successful you
are how intelligent you are where you're
from your background money in Money in
the
Bank when you push yourself that much
physically you can only get that
experience by doing what you've just
done not because of any of those out of
things I just mentioned before and
anyone can do
it you don't need the resource you just
need to give it a shot there's an
interesting conundrum that comes with
that statement and your resume of of
accomplishments which
is you start out on this exploration and
you're achieving things you didn't think
were possible for yourself and you're
continuing to raise that bar with the
goal the motivation the purpose the
intention of inspiring others to rethink
their own limitations but once you get
to a certain point where you're doing
extraordinary things
um that that really push other people's
imagination of what's possible you sort
of pivot away from being somebody who is
relatable to being this outlier and it's
much easier for somebody to dismiss you
as just some freak of nature well that's
will that's what he does but he's not
like other human beings and suddenly all
of that kind of accomplishments that
you're building towards trying to create
like a library of experiences that that
can be helpful for other people works at
Cross purposes because you've almost
done too much right it takes you out of
the position of being somebody who can
be a source of aspiration to one who is
a source of inspiration like
Michael Jordan is inspirational we can't
be Michael Jordan no but we can see the
every man go out and do something just
outside of our grasp and and be be and
and and we can aspire to that in our own
lives but once you run across the
country you go from aspirational to
inspirational and that changes the way
that people interact with you have you
noticed that or are you aware of that
kind of dynamic at play kind of but the
hardest thing I ever did was J grat
Salan Zen which is is
still big a bigger challenge than what a
lot of people might try and seek in
their life but every s every single
thing I did the first marathon
yo that was so hard and now I could go
and run a marathon now no issue but you
just have to understand that the process
starts at day one it's not you don't
have to look at me running across
America and be like I'm never going to
be able to do that if you'd have asked
me after I ran across the UK If I could
have done it I'd have been like
absolutely not you're insane
so every time I do something new
obviously it's going to go out a little
bit further and a little bit further but
if you're just starting out I don't
think I'm inherently special gifted
talented whatsoever at all I don't even
look like I should be an ultra Runner
but my mission and my reasoning behind
it will
always always push me to to keep going
as I said at the start seeing someone
fight for their
life especially someone so close to you
has changed me unequivocally
and I will always want to push the
boundaries to to find out what's what's
next in life and what's bigger and
better and I will always take another
step what have you learned about mindset
that has trickled into other areas of
your life outside of running um there's
there's definitely more of a tenac
tenacity to me than there was
before everything everything is mindset
and everything is pushing the limits and
when you have experienced things
physically and gone beyond the Realms
you thought possible it certainly frees
up the difficulty of the rest of
life like sending that email or like
I've had corporate jobs as well
Everything feels a little bit easier
because you can you can lean on those
experiences where you were
at 1% battery life left whatever and you
carry on going and then all of a sudden
you think you're complaining about
having to work for another hour or send
a few more emails like it it brings it
makes everything smaller and more
manageable for sure but it's earned it's
earned you can't manufacture that So for
anybody who's listening or watching you
have to step outside of your comfort
zone and stretch yourself in order to
develop the capacity to have that
perspective definitely there's another
trap that I see happening with a lot of
ultra athletes which is they start to
form an identity or an unhealthy
attachment with all of their
accomplishments and then in in you know
to your point of like chasing the dragon
it just becomes about the next craziest
thing and then just topping that and
topping that and always trying to top
the thing before it and that generally
isn't a great like Life Plan like it's
cool to go out and do hard things and I
encourage everybody to do that but at
some point you have to have a ballast in
your life that lives outside of those
Feats so how do you how do you make sure
that you're anchored you know in in in
meaningful ways that have nothing to do
with running probably because I love so
many other things aside from running
yeah I I'm not seeing this as a problem
yeah this is not this is not a a pothole
for you I don't think well un
uninterestingly I'll use Robbie as an
example so much cuz we're kind of
similar but very different at the same
time and he's my anchor for this kind of
[__] anyway when he wakes up in the
morning he can't wait to run when I wake
up in the morning I don't want to
[__] run I'm not like I don't wake up
and go yippy I can't wait to get my
miles in today I'm like like really do I
have to do that which kind of might be
hard to hear considering what I do but I
do it the reason I do it is I'm raising
money for charity I'm expanding life
experience I'm pushing myself to another
Lev level so whilst running is my
vehicle right now I don't think it's
always going to have to be where I push
where I push everything and put all my
chips into there's so many areas of life
outside of that that I love and I get
enjoyment from and I can push myself in
so whilst even when I was running I
still had some other ideas it's not I
don't think you're going to see me
in I don't know but you're not going to
see me in 20 years having done another
10 challenges like trying to one up what
I've already done cuz I probably don't
actually have enough time what is the
next thing that you're thinking about
doing I had an interesting
one well first and for the first one I
thought of was I believe I could get the
record for running across
Australia think distance-wise Brockman
alert yeah what is the record it's
whatever it is it's 6 60 mil a day I
think it's is it 48 days I can't
remember can't remember but that's what
Ned set out to do we had some chats
along the way when I was doing transcon
as well I love love say like I was in
Australia recently and I was with Ned
and we tried to FaceTime you but you
were occupied or I don't know what's
going
on and I was in London and I facetimed
you and you answered I was like I can't
believe you actually answered you're
like out running and you're like we're
doing a FaceTime call anyway go ahead
yeah Ned's a good guy and I have so I
have so much respect for him like that
being his first challenge incred I
understand why that took him where it
took him it's sick and yeah he's a good
dude but I think I could get that record
so if it stays the same that is I got a
lot of confidence from running across
the US and I think Australia is about
1,000 km less mhm but then there's
another part of me that wants to do
something slightly new and I just I had
I have this fantasy of running from
Istanbul in Turkey where the bridge goes
over to Asia basically hugging the
Mediterranean Coast all up through where
you start going up you go through Greece
and then up I can't remember the
countries there in the Czech Republic
I'd go across the top of Italy I
wouldn't go down because that would make
it extremely long I probably could but
in my head this is what I'm doing and
then southern France southern Spain
round of finish in Lisbon wow and that's
about the same distance that sounds
sexier it does yeah yeah that's more
it's like the comoo Run yeah this sounds
more yeah get a fleet of tians as your
crew vehicles and make I can't believe
that happened actually we're joking
because when you ran around Lake comoo
you had Teslas and and tians as your as
your crew vehicles that
was yeah only you would figure out how
to pull that off right yeah but that's
what that's where I want this space to
be I still want want it to be fun whilst
the Australia thing would be amazing
it's it's not similar and it is similar
to running across the US it's the same
country it's English-speaking people not
a lot of changes in 100 miles where is
when you're in Europe that's the most
beautiful thing about living in London
for me it's 2 hours you can be anywhere
else anywhere well 2 and a half 3 hours
you can be anywhere amazing in Europe
and imagine exper experiencing that on
foot it's my favorite thing to do when I
arrive in a new country put my shoes on
and go for a run without a route without
knowing anything and that's that on a
bigger scale and my fantasy for doing it
is it's it's not slogging trying to do
60 m a day it's more like maybe doing 30
m a day but actually experiencing the
places more yeah like a well if you just
did a marathon a day then you have lots
of cappuccino time I love capucino time
but that's that is the sort of7
Continental version of ultra running
like running across Australia it's like
all right aside from some hills in wa
like the terrain doesn't change that
much you're dealing with uh roadkill and
what does Ned call them like the the
truck trains whatever massive there
aren't they yeah and very few sort of
Scenic overlooks or places to even get
food right like it's just a you know
basically a mind-numbing mental exercise
yeah but hugging the Mediterranean and
going over mountains and all and going
into Villages it's like your own William
gge tour to France on foot yeah that's
that's the dream like I feel very I feel
very lucky where I can actually even
think about that as an
idea um so yeah it builds into
everything that I kind of love running
food travel seeing new places
experiencing culture and it's an amazing
speed at which to do it as well how do
you think about the storytelling aspect
of it how that's going to go down well
no just historically like with transcon
and everything obviously you know you
had Reese on board and chronicling this
whole thing and you know basically
having a you know a public lens on on
what you're doing and and an opportunity
in a platform to you know share ideas
and thoughts and and the experience as
it went
like as somebody who is of younger
generation than me like this is this is
what we do this is you know this is how
you kind of make your way in the world
in a certain respect right so how does
that play into how you think about how
you pursue your life and the challenges
you want to tackle and how you want to
comport yourself publicly it's
interesting because it's it's kind it's
almost like a necess evil once you're in
that space doing it it's like you're
always going to have to do it but in all
honesty my favorite times are when I'm
just alone pushing myself without anyone
sort they can know about it but not
there being a camera in my face so it's
always going to be a battle for me but I
also understand on the flip side of me
not loving it all the time at the end of
the day you've got so much to look back
at and how how fortunate are we in this
stay in time where you can have an
experience and it doesn't just live in
the memory bank you can relive it and
see it in a different way so I think it
will continue to be a part of what I do
some people may see it and get inspired
by it and try and do something
themselves like the amount of messages I
get from people saying they're about to
try their first challenge or they've
lived a similar experience and they're
going to try and push themselves like
it's it's very humbling to be any even
fractional positive influence for
someone trying to do something
and you will never understand even in
your experience as well you'll never
understand the scale of which that is
like the amount of people messaging you
there's 10 20 times the amount of people
that aren't so yeah for me it probably
always still be there
and I don't know if it will ever change
as I say I don't really plan too far in
my future
but yeah talk about Robbie a little bit
like what what do you think think makes
Robbie Ballinger so
special uh this is this is this is your
opportunity to send that love letter
come on buddy yeah he is he's one of the
most outside of my family he's the most
special person in my life as I said
earlier he understands me and I
understand him on a different level he
gives me a huge amount of confidence to
chase whatever I want to Chase and do it
with tenacity and
confidence and he's all he is always
always there from what as I said from
whatever challenge I've done he's been
the first to put his hand up and tried
to help in any way he could whether that
be in a physical way or even even if he
wasn't there at the time he'd always be
pushing so that guy has given me a 110%
since the moment I met him and I've I
feel forever indebted to him there's not
a lot there's nothing I can do to
actually pay him back for what he's done
and I would not have ran across the us
if it wasn't for him I wouldn't have
finished running the length of the UK if
he wasn't there that guy has shaped my
life in such a positive
way it goes goes kind of beyond words
and he he as a person is so special as
you said he's he just wants to do things
for other people and he's also a [__]
rock star like he is he is rock and roll
he's I want to be Robbie Ballinger when
I grew up put it that
way well said yeah he's a he's a beast
and all the things I see him do punk
rock too oh yeah you know he's he's uh
channeling a little Hunter S Thompson a
little Willie Nelson those are his guys
yeah our favorite quote from uh huness
Thompson is when the going gets weird
the weird turns weird turn pro mhm which
is what we feel like when when you
really push the boundaries of things and
when you're at the upper limits of
physical output you know in Ultra you
get like the thousand yard
stare that's when it gets weird and
that's the time to turn pro that's when
we do our best work yeah did you have
any kind of hallucinations or any of
that kind of stuff not on the America
not on the America run no there only on
Codine only on coding yeah I need some
hardcore drugs but that's
why where I want to explore next and
where I know where the dragon lays is in
these 200 mile 200 mile plus races so
helping Robbie when he did the Tesla
challenge that was what 20 240 248 I
think yeah and he did that in 77 hours
like he got to that place on at the end
of day one and kind of stayed there
until he finished on day four yeah that
looked like a rough one day three and a
bit crazy and then also helping him with
the speed project which he did solo he
ran 100 miles in the first 20 hours
stopped for like two stopped for an hour
and 40 minutes and went out and carried
on again and we should say that that is
a run from Los Angeles to Las
Vegas most of it is teams trading off
like a relay right there a few sadistic
people that do it solo so the and you
can choose your route right you can go
whatever you whichever way you want to
get there that's the coolest thing about
it's a no rules race you have a start
point and an end point and it's just
like how about
it but you start like pier in Santa
Monica is is that where it started
exactly and you finish I don't know
where in Las Vegas but it's one of the
points it's where the big Las Vegas sign
old sign yeah yeah so yeah being on
those experiences with him and now
having done the US run like I understand
to get to those places where I want to
be it's got to be a shorter amount of
distance but very aggressive mhm that's
how you that's how you get to the your
upper limitations when it's too long and
you have a a time
schedule it's like risk aversion whereas
if it's a straight SL you're you're just
managing efficiency yeah if it's a
straight so would you do like Moab 240
and like that that's the one on the list
I was listening to the um goggin's
latest book on the run and when when he
was talking about that when he came back
from his injury yeah that 240 mile race
and obviously the first year it was when
he had to he went to hospital and went
back to finish it off but wasn't
official right he well he went off
course too I think yeah by about 13
miles cuz his Pace had took him the
wrong way but yeah that's yeah he went
to the hospital and then he went back
where he left off and finished it even
though it was however many days later
yeah but that's where I want to go to
that will be the next iteration of what
I do like obviously that European run
might be a big one along the way maybe
in 2
years more sooner I'll be I want to do
the big 200 mile races cuz it will also
be interesting like as you as you said
it's one of the fastest times to run
across the country but the way I talk
about myself and how I do things is not
thinking I'm professional in any real
way shape or form but I would like to
understand where I I am in that group of
people that are doing right the gnarly
[__] like consistently and then as I
said I don't I don't know where I want
to go if I do one of those races and
place well like do I want to leave some
of the other fun [__] behind and go more
that way like I don't know but that's
that will be my next experience for sure
interesting um in the short term though
you're going to do Berlin the Berlin
Marathon we were chatting before the
podcast and I was suggesting that you do
almost no run leading up to that and
just do a couple speed sessions and just
see how much is in the tank as an
experiment yeah which is kind of the
approach you're taking right it was like
you got to recover yeah it's a it's a
tough one because for me the way I'm
thinking about it is it's either the
best foundation of all time to go and
run a fast Marathon having ran 3,000
miles or it's way too close it's 16
weeks after I finished running across
the US so I'm probably still fried and
won't be able to do it but yeah it'll be
an interesting thing to see like I gave
myself I finished at the end of May I
was giving myself the whole of June to
do whatever the [__] I wanted which I've
generally done but even now I've got
back into training earlier than I
thought I thought I would have done just
because it's part of my life and I love
it and going to parties and fashion
weeks all right but I actually don't
like it as much as I like normal life
asides from traveling so yeah you when
is Berlin Berlin is the end of September
I don't know exactly the date but it'll
be one of the last Sundays mhm so yeah
if I so July I'll have 12 weeks so I'm
going to get into a training program
then and sorry I can't do your idea of
just doing a couple of couple of speed
sessions but I just go to the gym and
get like get jacked yeah get jacked and
then just go to the track like twice a
week yeah and see what happens but I it
will be in I mean listen you have this
huge base but you've been you've been
running like 10 11 minutes and it miles
you know so you got to throw down a
little bit yeah we'll see we'll see how
it goes but I'm I'm actually looking
forward to starting and seeing what that
first speed session feels like because I
haven't got out of third gear
in a long time yeah you got you got to
tap back into that yeah um what do you
say to the person who's listening to
this or or watching it and suddenly
feeling inspired but has never really
tackled anything difficult like how do
you how do you you know prod that person
off the couch and and get them into into
action on
something it's might be hard to take but
just [__] do it like what whatever it
is you're thinking about the more you
procrastinate about it the less likely
you are to do it so if it's your first
marathon book one just book one CU as
soon as you've paid your money for it
and it's in six months time that's going
to give you some gumption to actually do
something about it but
we live in a world where there's too
many dreams that go missing and you
might miss an opportunity to be here
doing this [__] talking with you like
quite literally four and a half years
ago I was doing [__] all I was a
semi-professional rugby player
pretending to be a model sometimes like
nothing was really happening but as soon
as I took that first step it suddenly
led to the second and the third and the
how many steps I've taken since but
action will always be any kind of
intention you've said that you're not
innately super talented no uh but if you
had to declare a strength or an edge
what would that be like what is what is
your advantage what is it that you know
propelled you to do these things outside
of you know what happened with your
mother Etc like what is it about you
that's uniquely you
that
you think put you ahead of the pack here
I think that that experience sped up the
process but I I have to know I have to
know what I'm capable of be that where
does that come from I don't actually
know I'm not sure what's what's where
that is from inside me it's maybe it's
growing up
like my experience of growing up
everything was great but there was a
part of me that always so my dad came
from a council flat which is government
housing in the UK he got into carpentry
when he was probably 15 he bought his
first house when he was I think 18 or 19
by the time he was 22 he had bought his
parents who were in that Council flat an
apartment so he'd set his parents up and
himself up ready for life as I said no
thrills or whatever but he also at the
same time as being somewhat not
successful and given us the life we have
there was always a safety thing about
him like he didn't want to lose what he'
built and I understand that entirely and
I I love him and respect him so much and
wouldn't change him from the world for
the world but I remember growing up and
certain things happening in business
where he wouldn't get paid or someone
would play him around like a bigger
company and I I didn't understand why he
wouldn't go and almost attack that angle
so
for
me seeing him going through that and
playing it safe and thinking what he
could have done whilst I'm still proud
of him there's a part of me that I don't
like that unknown area I want to know
what that unknown area is even if it
means that I [__] up everything else
before it so that might be where it
stems from
but yeah we're here once when my man
passed away like I said tomorrow isn't
promised I'm going to do what I want to
do today and I'm going to enjoy it
because it's everyone says it and it's
cliche but you don't know what's
happening tomorrow so please try and
please enjoy it and I also have no
dependencies like I don't have a
girlfriend I don't have a dog don't have
children so whilst I can I'm going to
invest in experience invest in
experience yeah yeah that's that's super
interesting about your dad I mean
obviously it makes total sense why he
would make those choices coming from
where he came from um and why you sort
of being a product of him and growing up
in a bit of a different circumstance
would would be interested in another
choice but I think on top of that you
know I have this this this spidey sense
that your mother who obviously I didn't
know but I've only heard you speak about
in such with such
reverence profoundly impacted your sense
of your own capacity like this person
who clearly believed in you and
supported you and wanted good things for
you in a very healthy way like um not in
a controlling way or in a you know
projecting way or anything like that or
in or in any kind of enmeshment way but
truly from the best place gave you a
sense of yourself that led you to
believe that you were capable of doing
whatever you set your mind to and I
think that's so powerful is that does
that track yeah I think that's very true
as well and I kind of got
those feeling free from her even my dad
as well growing up like even around exam
time or whatever I was never sat down
and said you need to study it was like
if you're going to study you're going to
do it because you know it's good for you
but also my mom she W she changed
careers quite a lot of times even
towards the end of her life like she was
a nurse for the most part she was a
nurse at school in the police force and
then she left and opened up a vintage
te- room and our local town she was a
very good Baker so she had a vintage t-
room and then from there she was always
she was always a Kean Garder as well so
the time she passed away she was
enrolled in uh a college in London for
garden design and I think seeing her be
somewhat Fearless in career changes even
when she could have just kept it
comfortable and whatever has led me to
feel like if I want to switch things up
or try something new at any time I can
and I was always I was always told I
could do that like I didn't go to
university or college when I finished
school I went traveling to Australia and
Thailand for 6 months and I was almost I
wasn't pushed into it but when I when I
said any idea to them it was almost it
was always let's figure out how we can
do it they weren't going to denounce
what I was trying to do and say you need
to take the normal route of Life which
everyone else well not everyone else but
most people do wow that's cool this
became a parenting podcast it did yeah
know yeah I mean
you know as being somebody who's older
than you who thinks about parenting a
lot like I'm always thinking about what
the best way you know is to support my
kids um and what I'm arriving at is very
different from the way that I was raised
yeah in so many ways and I think we we
all parent either in admiration of our
parents we try to we try to live up to
the way we were parented or we parent in
opposition to you know for whatever
needs didn't get met in the way that we
wish they had yeah that makes a lot of
sense and like your mother I mean it's
it's I think it's really powerful like
the way that she raised you yeah and
it's it's almost like I've kind of
understood this by talking to you about
it so it's it's cool for me too but yeah
I just I always felt like I could I
could go and try and do anything I
wanted to and that was it's such a
beautiful thing and a POS a powerful
position to be yeah to feel like you're
supported in whatever way you want to
direct direct your attention yeah and
that's why I've always tried to squeeze
the most out of life I've never saved
that much I've always I've always been
putting it out there for experience but
my parents and what they did allowed me
that freedom and I I never I always know
that I was never going to mess it up too
much like I would never push the boat
out too far but yeah that that feeling
of just being able to give it a go yeah
how old are you now 29 I had a tough
paper I don't know but 29 29 and look at
the breadth of and depth of experiences
you've already had yeah it's it's
actually crazy and it's there've always
been the best and most expansive periods
of my life and now everything I do has
come because of that mhm and again going
back to what we said like purpose is the
most beautiful feeling in the world
feeling like you have a purpose of
something to do and you're also getting
something out of it but at the same time
might be help helping other people
is beyond yeah in thinking about your
mom and then in thinking about Robbie
the the the the consistent theme is
service right these are people who are
givers in their nature right but do you
feel as a result of being on the
receiving end of so much
um you know so much so much help and
support uh a responsibility to pay that
forward and be of service to someone
else definitely on who's coming up in in
in you know the the shadow of what
you've done definitely yeah it's um the
best almost the best feelings are the
ones that you experience with other
people or help other people help other
people do so when Robbie did his Tesla
challenge when he did this the speed
Project M being there and being able to
help him achieve that and knowing that
he's grateful to you for for that is is
incredibly special and being able to
shape something someone's life in a
positive way is even more special so at
this time in my life
it's it's kind of just been me about me
but that next phase of life it's the
same as having a family or whatever like
I'm I can't wait for that moment where
it really becomes about someone
else I want to end this with another
quote another thing that I heard you say
another Talisman or another Mantra which
is if I can I will m
yeah that was that was from Robbie as
well so the background to that was it
was during the speed project um it was
on the last day I think there was there
was 30 mil left of the race
and I can't remember the the lady's name
but a woman had won it she' just got
into Las Vegas and behind Rob in about
10 miles behind there were I think four
or five guys one had been jousting with
a couple days before on this incredible
section um through these mountains and
he was it was like Offroad right like
you guys were just like Biv whacking
yeah over these I can't believe the cars
got up there I was like how is how are
you even how did you even figure out
that this would be the way to go and
that it would pan out and finding
someone that I don't know like 140 mies
into a race and them racing against each
other right shows up there but it was it
was funny because we had stopped and
Robbie was really down in the dumps like
down he was having a nap in the back of
the car I don't know if it was an angel
Sent From Heaven or whatever but on a
random Side Road next to the highway
which was a dirt road give even calling
it a dirt road is giving it more service
than it deserves I can't believe anyone
else would be there a guy pulled up
behind us and obviously he needed to get
past so we had to wake Robbie up and in
that time as well um the speed project
Instagram page had gone live and they'
had shown that the lady had finished
finished the race and they had live
trackers on everyone so they'd also seen
that Robbie was 30 m out but then a
group of four other Runners were like 10
miles behind him so we had to wake
Robbie up so he wasn't in the car when
we moved it prior to that you didn't
even know that somebody was on his heels
no idea that's another interesting thing
about this race you just don't know
right so it's me it's mentally like you
just have to you just keep going and it
can be to your demise or or benefit but
when we woke him up I knew at that time
I needed to tell him cuz he'd be more
pissed off if I didn't
and he very quickly switched in his
brain he went from being down and out to
okay I'm not going to win but the only
way I'm going to get out of this feeling
proud of myself is if I give absolutely
everything from this point on and he was
like immed he was like I'm going to need
a gel every 3 miles and in my head I'm
getting so gassed I'm like this guy is
about to go [__] crazy and I'm I'm
here for it is like I need a gel every
every uh 5K um and if I have to stop
before I finish it's going to be because
I'm at zero not cuz I'm anywhere above
that not one not 2% not anything and I
remember along the way like being so
buzzing to Crum through this stupid
experience of running 30 miles having
run 200 miles already in 3 days and just
being so impressed at his level of
application of just continuing to move
Peter John who was with us on the
transcon as well he was there and Robbie
would be running along and he'd
gradually curve over and people would
literally tap him and be like can't
stand up and he'd like rise back up and
carry on running but when I joined them
at the end I remember him just saying to
me there was this thing that kept going
over over and in my head and it's if I
can I will that's a very powerful thing
it's like how I said earlier of can you
take another step you basically always
can so if I can I
will if you think about that really
deeply you can and you will it's
profound it's it's funny how a short
sentence can mean so much if you tap
into it enough but I thought about that
the whole way across America as well it
was a powerful thing when I was down and
out was can I yes I will I think that's
a good place to end it sounds good to me
is it possible for people to still
donate to the Charities for the transcon
it was going to end but we can keep it
open there no act there's no actual de
end why do there need to be an ending
there doesn't have to be so name them
and we'll make sure that we put the
links up in the in the show notes so it
will be on a GoFundMe page which I can
give you the link to it's Wills run
across America and we're raising money
for McMillan cancer support in the UK um
who helped my mom personally through her
battle and helped millions of people in
the country there and then the American
Cancer Society in the US I wanted to
raise money for cancer chariots on both
sides of the pond they offer a similar
service to McMillan but they also do
cancer research as well so two amazing
Charities do an amazing thing and I'm
very humbled and grateful that I get to
represent them and they support me in
the way they do as well good on you mate
thanksa yeah it's uh it's inspiring what
you're doing especially at such a young
age and with so many years ahead of you
to figure out how you want to Channel
all this energy and just you know
massive respect dude like what you've
accomplished is extraordinary and the
manner in which you comport yourself and
and speak about and kind of report back
from the front lines of your experiences
is is really inspiring so I appreciate
it cheers [__] good to be than man
[Music]
cheers that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change in
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. Rich
roll.com if you'd like to support the
podcast the easiest and most impactful
thing you can do is to subscribe to the
show on Apple podcasts on Spotify and on
YouTube and leave a review Andor comment
supporting the sponsors who support the
show is also important and appreciated
and sharing the show or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at Rich roll.com
Today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason Cameo with additional audio
engineering by Kale Curtis the video
edition of the podcast was created by
Blake Curtis with assistance by our
creative director Dan Drake portraits by
Davy Greenberg graphic and social media
assets courtesy of Daniel CIS thank you
Georgia Wy for copywriting and website
management and of course our theme music
was created by Tyler Patt trapper Patt
and Harry matys appreciate the love love
the support see you back here soon peace
plance
[Music]
namaste